you know how sometimes your your doing
what I call it random acts of kindness
but nobody sees it
okay you do something good and no one
knows what you did and what am I talking
I'm talking about you know Mario was
just telling me what he did for somebody
and he encouraged them to do an event
and nobody's ever heard about it and he
and I I asked him about it he brought it
up thinking you know no one knows you
did that
I know because he does it all the time
but sometimes you do good for people and
in business it's it's in life you do it
so many times that nobody sees it and
you get this scourge like why am i doing
anything that if nobody sees it I
remember I read a I was told a story I'm
driving right now
kanan Road headed to Malibu I heard a
story by man five and a half years ago
man named Eric who was in the Navy many
many years ago was in the Navy many many
years ago right here by Santa Barbara
and he said one time my sister ditch
school and her and her beautiful friend
were going to the beach and I begged my
sister to take her with me so she
initially said no but finally she took
her and took him and this is back we're
talking 60 years ago cuz he's in his
late 70s this man Eric 60 years ago he's
13 years old so 65 years ago seven years
ago you're talking 1950s 1960s 1940s
1950s and he says I got under the wagon
week we go and while you're driving to
the beach on Las Virgenes or canid
there's this tunnel that you go through
he says the wagon breaks down and
we have no idea how what to do I'm 13
years old my sister 16 years old I don't
know what to do with that what are we
gonna do with that and he says a man
pulls up in his truck with a dog in the
truck with them he's in his mid 20s late
20s I guess out he says can I help you
with anything says yeah you know we have
a flat tire here and we don't know how
to change no problem goes back gets
everything comes down changes a tire and
says you kids take care of yourself
there's no problem they say sir what's
your name
so my name is Ronald Reagan interesting
story and you wonder if I'm hearing
about that story about Ronald Reagan and
he ends up becoming a president and some
say one of the best presidents we've
ever had you know he won 49 out of 50
states loved by Democrats and
Republicans kind of like Kennedy was
loved by both sides no one do you think
Reagan knew at that point one big is
going to be a president and another
person who was in the Navy is gonna tell
this story to another person and this
story's gonna be told years after he
passes away do you think when he's in
that moment he knows it I don't know if
he does I don't think he does at that
time he was trying to be an actor in
Hollywood and his career was sport
announcing and all the stuff that he was
doing when he left Dixon so many times
when you do good and you think no one's
watching
just remember the goodness of doing good
you know one you feel good about it but
second is when you do it hundreds of
times over a 10 15 20 year period
eventually your reputation follows and
many people start talking about it this
concept works in life it works in
business it works in if you ever
planning on getting into politics it
works in anything
when that reputation spreads people want
to have somebody like that in their
lives and they want to do business with
someone like that in their lives so
today for no reason at all go do
something good for someone and if you
want to share with us on the bottom tell
us what you did I'd love to hear about
it but today just for no reason at all
help somebody out today one you'll feel
good
- hopefully becomes a habit and
continuously once you do that 10 15 20
years from now your reputation will
start spreading to everybody else as
well
it's my message of the week to you and
yes I am doing my best to drive safe
be sure to subscribe to the channel take
care bye bye